whenever we first got married i was um i
thought i had it all figured out i was
full of pride in all areas and i was
afraid of her leaving i never let her
inside to to know who i really was is it
cool if i go all larry king on you i
aggravated just as many situations as i
helped because i felt like it was my
role to always argue and to make sure my
voice was heard it kept everything
totally separate
she had the bank account i had a bank
account and we split the bills right
down the middle those first few months
years that we were together we weren't
really a married couple more like
roommates yeah
we had this massive epic fight about
paying this i think it was like an 87
dollar i remember specifically this 87
dish network bill because you didn't
watch tv that month and so you were not
going to pay the dish network bill
you're way too cute a couple to be
separated i know right
give me high five
good girl that's the most spoiled dog
you ever seen in hawaii you see your big
bucket of toys right there she's well
taken care of i aggravated just as many
situations as i helped you know you say
we should go left i say we should turn
right three times obviously what we were
doing was not working i mean we were
headed for a train wreck in a big way
we are all a little bit nerdy about the
things we care about
am i right i guess i i think so i was
i've listened to the show for two weeks
i was laughing about all the stupid
people out there before i realized that
i was one of those stupid people and i
knew for sure that i needed to take this
home to my wife and and that this was
gonna be the first thing that we grasped
to hold up and did together i said
honey i think we need to read this book
we need to follow this program and get
out of debt and she said okay when chad
brought this in i was
i was filled with immediate dread he
didn't know about you know my two
student loans he didn't know about the
victoria's secret credit card i was kind
of had mixed feelings one part of me was
like really
you know really and now we're gonna walk
through these baby steps and it's gonna
change our lives it was the first time i
think
all i'll say even in my entire life that
i was 150 percent honest with somebody i
had never had that in any relationship
those pride walls got broken down and i
remember it hadn't been a week after we
did our first budget probably that
that's the first time that we sat down
to pray together man things changed you
know from then on it was like oh my gosh
you know i love this lady i can be
myself around her he could take me at my
worst and still still love me still like
me and so um i felt like we were married
for the first time that was another
commitment that we made to each other
was that we're gonna we're gonna spend
all of our money together we're gonna
stop
bib into each other about anything we're
just going to be up front and if the
other one can't handle it you can't
handle it you know
if i married up you know this is the
secret to my success right here so amen
it's easy for me but for the other guys
out there i don't know what you are
going to do
chad became a leader he became
not just the guy i married
but
like the love of my life i love
everything about him i have no doubt
that if i follow where he goes that
we're going to be successful and really
happy
like i said before i wouldn't be
anything if it wasn't for her the first
thing that i think about is her inner
beauty
and just how
how wonderful it is and how how good it
makes me feel i can't mess this up you
know
i have to i have to do better so that we
get better and we end up where we want
to go we're just adding fuel to the
y'all are crazy fire
we are crazy if there's anything that
i've learned from this um from this
journey is that
i can trust my wife i can trust god and
i can trust dave's plan to work every
time i will never be more proud of
anything that we do together um then you
know may 24th 2013 we were debt free
all right count it down 142 thousand
dollars and 29 months paid off let's
hear a debt free scream three two one
we're dead free